when did I know Michael would be the
Michael we see today I saw with inhale
this wheel yeah we sell shoes but it's
not about you
this is about something far far greater
[Applause]
[Music]
I am Howard and white some call me H and
this is my life
in sneakers
[Music]
my father left us we didn't have
anywhere to go so we moved with my
mother's sister kind in the middle of
the woods and they say they let you play
basketball they own that new high school
down the road I couldn't play but they
quit neither so I was on the basketball
team it was Dougie's Dwight my science
teacher who say it if you're gonna be a
basketball player you gotta have coppers
and if you bring me ten dollars I'll get
you some Converse so I went and I looked
on the side of the road and find soda
bottles and I cast them in and came up
with ten dollars and gave them to Dougie
twice he knows sneakers
told me I was as good as anybody
that finally played in college tore one
knee up my senior year high school tore
the other one up my senior year college
and I coached after I played at Maryland
The Freshman John Lucas who came in and
took my place I tried to help him become
the best guy he could be the best player
he could be that was the person that
came to me
and said there's this great job with
Nike is it with who
he said with Nike
[Music]
[Applause]
when did I know in essence Michael would
be the Michael we see today
I have a feeling for
things and when Mom and Pop and MJ we
all came here you feel something
once we signed them then we really spend
a lot of time together you know I would
go I would stay right at his place put
him come to DC he would stay at my
little house we play table tennis
that would be
that wasn't that acceptable he went home
he ordered a ping pong table then he got
them to put ping pong tables
at the Birdo center after their practice
facility he would not accept
ing Armstrong said this one time and
that must agree he said Michael never
lost
he either won or learn
I saw with inhale this wheel is not
about basketball
thanks for the world needed another
basketball shoot a lot of people were
great but I was looking for something
that could change the way people saw
themselves
think it would be my favorite designer
take a Hatfield when Tate came on board
and the three can be uh that would take
Tinker to Michael's house I would let
him go through the cars and let him go
through the closets and let him just
have access to what Michael was they
don't know how in the hell he came up
with them damn things
I'm like okay you saw what that made you
see this
but they're mad it's so different
one of the most interesting shoes
I thought was the other level you know
is take a talk to him about that and I
mean MJ well yeah yeah yeah yeah man
this is I can see kids wearing it to
proms I can see this thing is going to
be huge and and remember this was before
people were wearing sneakers everywhere
this was like out of left field patent
leather they were different than what
anyone had ever seen or could imagine
obviously now we can see with hindsight
what that did
and they still selling them at Christmas
it changed the game
[Music]
my choice in shoes was the two because I
got to name that and it was the
imagination
suit
flying through the air and it was Just
My Imagination Running Away with me just
the nuances of what that means when you
talk about bad Italian leather the
quarter and they're the wings of a duck
you kidding me to get the wings only
eight shoe how high can we go
hear the wings
man h on the back
Dove Wings on the side
that's pretty cool the H white Air
Jordan 2 giving kids a chance through
scholarships
that they would have never known they
got a lot to do with basketball we
started a program brand called
fundamentals because MJ said his
teachers meant so much to him we would
give money to all of these teachers that
they sent in proposals to want to do
something in their school that wanted to
help all the way to scholarships
they're giving heads some baddest life
[Music]
sneakers for me when I think of my
journey I literally points of
inspiration I'm looking for that exact
same kid that sold soda bottles they
come up with ten dollars to buy or pay
of card first
and all of this came from a
collaboration of individuals and people
in companies around a single young man
from Chapel Hill
that together we might inspire
the world
to be better
[Music]